all right so once you're on your
Raspberry Pi the first thing you want to
do is open up your terminal and we're
going to need to make sure that we have
the dev tools now if you followed all my
tool or all my tutorials up until this
point you should be all set but just in
case let's make sure and sorry let me
move all this lose the resistor and all
this stuff okay
just to be sure let's make sure we have
it so to do that we're going to type
sudo and add sub - get install Python
and then we want Python RPI
Die GPIO and we'll hit enter and like I
said if you've followed my tutorials up
to this point it should say that you
already have this and it's all updated
and all this stuff but if not you it
might take you a little bit to get
through everything but otherwise that's
really all you have to make sure you
have to have that GPIO stuff enabled on
your Python or your Raspberry Pi so once
we have that done now we're free to
actually make the program so let's go
ahead and do that now ok so what we're
gonna want to do is we're going to open
up a Python 2 7 so just open up idle
here and wait a second is it's opening
that for us and what we're gonna want to
do is go file new window and we can go
ahead and close out of this price
sucking up some resources so now let's
actually make our program so the first
thing that we're gonna want to do is we
have to import the GPIO stuff so first
once you import capital R capital P
lowercase I dot capital all caps GPIO
and then we want to just like import
that as just a lowercase GPIO you can
import it as whatever you want you can
even import it I think it's IO or
something if that's not conflicting
which it's not so you could do that and
then the other thing we're going to just
import just for the purposes of making a
basic program is we're gonna import on
and just one more thing that I suggest
that we do is GPIO dot set warnings and
then in the parentheses say false what
it's probably gonna do for a lot of you
is when we run the program it's gonna
throw it's not an error like your
program will still work I guess it's
kind of an error but it's a warning
that's exactly what it is it's a warning
and it's gonna say this channel is
already in use but it's not a big deal
so if you want that to go away you can
type that otherwise I'm just going to
comment it out for now so you can see it
what what I'm talking about but you can
put that in or not it really doesn't
matter it's not gonna affect anything so
the next thing that we want to do in our
little program here is we're gonna say
you want to activate basically the pin
that you plan to use so the way that
we're gonna do that is first you go GPIO
oops you pull it dot set mode and we're
going to use GPIO dot capital DCM and I
believe it's here where you can say dot
something else I forget what it is but
you can say dot something else and then
you can refer the actual physical pin
number rather than its programming name
but we're gonna use the programming and
then the next thing we're gonna do is
say GPIO dot setup and then here the
first parameter is going to be the pin
number and then we're gonna treat this
GPIO pin as an output this would be a
good time to also mention a couple
things about the Raspberry Pi GPIO the
Raspberry Pi has absolutely no
over-voltage protection so what this
means is as you know your Raspberry Pi
is powered by a five volt charge coming
into it and the GPIO pins are directly
connected to your process
sir so if you say you want to make an RC
car and even got input-output going on
or you let's say you've got like a
sensor or a camera so I mean it's like
taking high power and you've got an
external power supply somewhere besides
on the PI or besides what is powering
your PI if you send a signal back
because the signal is actually just a
Bolton right god I wish I could think I
forget what the charge is but in a
second you'll see that what the signal
you send is either a high or a low and I
think high is like one volt that it
sends as a signal and then low is just
it sends a zero volt and so it just
changes its mind basically and that's
how you're sending a zero or a one so to
speak this is how you interact
physically with these things so but
someone maybe someone can post down
there if I figure it out I'll maybe
annotate or something what the voltage
exactly is might be like 1.7 I really
can't remember anyway
anyway it sends a charge and but if you
send a charge into the GPIO that you say
you send in a nine volt what you send in
nine volts your you could fry your PI
and so obviously that's not something
you want to do so until you're
comfortable with doing circuitry I would
not suggest you use your GPIO pins for
input that's just my suggestion unless
unless everything that's powering your
circuit is your PI but as soon as you
add an external powering supply beside
your five volt you know plug into the PI
that's a whole different ballgame you
got to be really careful and make sure
you set up your circuit correctly so
your input is not too much so anyways
continuing right along we're going to
use the pin as an output pin because you
can use it obviously as input as well so
now what we want to do is create our our
program so what we're going to do is
let's say just to give it something
interesting and we could just make it
turn on or something but let's actually
make it like a real program and so what
I'd like to do is like
mimic a door lock right so someone comes
up to the door asked them for their
password if they enter the correct
password the door unlocks for a few
seconds just enough time for them to
open the door and then it automatically
relaxed itself again waiting for another
password entry so let's make a program
to do that so we want this persona let's
program to run all the time so we're
going to encase it in a while true loop
and the next thing we're gonna want to
do is GPIO dot output 18 and the GPIO
are the signal we want to send is a high
signal so think of what we're gonna do
is when the the LED light is on that's
going to signal as if the lock is
engaged and then when the LED is off the
lock is not engaged a lot of times on
locks you're going to have like you know
some sort of light that denotes what's
going on so if the light is on that
means the lock is engaged if the light
it's off that means the lock is unlocked
so now what we're going to have is we're
going to pass code so if the hash code
equals raw input and within here you
know we're gonna put the question what
is so anybody that's not familiar with
our program I gonna put in that you know
a numerical value of pipe but that's not
actually what we're looking for so roll
the tricksters now if the passcode
equals awesome then what we're gonna do
is we're gonna say GPIO output to pin 18
and the signal we're innocent is GPIO
dot L o w4
are you know metaphorical block so to
speak or otherwise it's going to turn
off our LED light and then what we want
to do is we're going to time sleep for
four seconds so the person has four
seconds to like you know open the door
you know obviously I have to shut it in
that amount of time it's the lock is
usually you know electric lock and so if
it shuts the door can shut while it's
already locked usually not a big deal so
we've got that so they got four seconds
to open the door before they'd have to
re-enter the password else let's say
they the past
entered is not awesome then we're going
to say GPIO dot output and what we want
to do here even though we don't we
wouldn't have to do this right because
we've already while true the output is
high already but just as a you know a
bit of a fail-safe we're going to go
ahead and say GPIO dot just to be
certain if we're gonna send one more
high signal and we'll just go ahead and
say print and then you know call police
but anyway so that's our program and if
you're not comfortable with Python
programming I do have a bunch of basic
Python tutorials it's just kind of
assumed at this point you know Python
programming so if you don't check out
some of my basic tutorials but most of
these programs I mean I assume that
almost anybody brand new to programming
could probably see what's going on right
this is maybe a little confusing but
it's just this is just like always so
true you could also say while one is
less than two right it's always going to
be true so but or you can just say true
this is setting the pin this is defining
a variable pass code as raw input which
allows a user to put an input and then
if the pass code is awesome and it does
this otherwise it's going to do this so
pretty pretty simple and if you don't
know programming but as we continue on
it might be useful for you to learn some
programming so now what we're gonna do
is we're gonna save this and just kind
of note where you're saving it in our
case we're saving in his slash home
slash PI I'm just gonna put it here it's
fine and make sure you save it as a dot
pi so we're gonna say GPIO example dot
PI okay so we'll go ahead and hit save
there and sure enough all set now the
next few things that we need to do is
first of all we have to connect it to
our Raspberry Pi but one more thing I
just want to bring up is you can't run
this program from here for example if we
go to run this it's going to throw an
error because we're not
running it as a super user so wait a
second right we don't have any access to
dev mint now the reason for this is
because this program is actually trying
it is going to talk directly to our
processor and we could do some serious
damage so just being the system that it
is it's not gonna let us do that unless
we're running as the root user or a
super user which is what pseudo is for
super years super user do I think is
what it stands for
so anyway now let's pop over to our
Raspberry Pi and let's plug in
everything and then we'll come back over
to this screen and begin running our
program so let me go do that